moi je crois qu'à l'export on sait pas
qu'on va aller loin qu'on y va je crois
que c'est justement quand on n'est pas
du tout sérieux dans cette aventure est
d'ailleurs de aussi je croyais que
c'était le cunnilingus le ciment du
couple - oui je pense non mais je pense
que ce jeu là il est encore une fois
c'est ça c'est de jouer et de ne pas
être trop sérieux parce que la fidélité
est fidèle à soi à kidal à l'autre c'est
comme cette histoire de de liberté dans
le couple vous disais tout à l'heure que
c'était important le choix des mots
souvent je parle de liberté dans le
couple et les gens entendent infidélité
je trouve ça extraordinaire rue je
trouve ça incroyable la liberté pour moi
c'est de laisser la possibilité à
l'autre de revenir dans le lit conjugal
le soir en ayant envie pour moi c'est ça
c'est à dire qu'il aurait le choix
éventuellement de parvenir mais il
revient et c'est beaucoup plus
philosophique c'est beaucoup plus
poétique c'est beaucoup plus romantique
que
[Musique]